and antenna tonight Canada let's go you
guys have an awful time today yeah this
is so-so
I mean how much fun did you guys have
infinity times infinity that's how much
fun we had this is another question on a
scale I heard for example yeah there was
some romances going on ten ten there's a
lot of romance inside abroad I'm not
voting I don't know oh yeah romances
romances I got James and Brian pregnant
yeah I'm not playing to be a good father
I'll be a good father
oh no I will not be propagated so talk
about the idea of actually finding
someone that your parents are okay with
is that a difficult it's pretty easy he
just has to like walk in and you know
like be awake oh my God he's being so
charming he says grounded and he knows
who he uses ridiculous what about
yourself
are you ever nervous about the guys you
bring home or your parents tough to
please no they're very under they're
very accepting and wonderful I'm not
with my sisters boyfriends who are all
have been great guys I'm very very mean
I have perfected the death stare and I
have had to write formal apologies yeah
yeah yeah right now he's yeah whoa yeah
even from the side I'm freaky yeah me
too I might even look at that she's got
a little bit of a bedroom aisle I'm
scared like turn it on well crush on you
and I can't even yeah she's got a really
great gal gee what about yourself me
because there's two types of guys
there's guys that parents like guys that
parents don't really like are you a
parent guy oh no I'm a parent guy oh I'm
always worried I've always won in that
category
I've had girls I've dated girls whose
mothers like me more than the girl did
like I've had high school just been you
know like straight up the Graduate yeah
I've been there and dad's for the most
part of it pretty good pretty good yeah
pretty good but the moms like I can get
a mom I can get them on you via that
accent with the accent it's pretty good
which accent thank you very much it's
pretty good
can you tell me what I would have to do
to win over some parents of girls I'm
dating right now in the accent in accent
ask you a question I know you live in
Toronto you came here all you can eat
that's a nice thing to say I'm just
laying it out just drop your truth
yeah I'm just gonna laying out back
mom's willing grace is that there's some
rumors that that might come back yes
would you like to see my back I would I
think it would be fun I don't know
anything yet there's nothing official
but it would be such a great time
different hit pack right now you know
because I'm you know there's it's mostly
about comedy but then you know we'd
obviously be able to throw in a few
little things here and there
yeah many birthdays on